so this is kind of a urgent announcement
that I have to make as you can see on
the screen who's opposed to by a modern
Erasmus that was put up on their CP wiki
probably I don't know but less than an
hour ago I don't know if you remember
the last video that I made on Andrzej
dachshund but he's back SCP community
six months ago we alerted you to the
actions of Andrzej dachshund a Russian
man who's illegally registered an
illegitimate trademark for SCP within
the Eurasian customs union he has used
said trademark to threaten and extort
illegitimate sellers of SCP merchandise
and an addition is guilty of copyright
infringement as his own merchandise
completely violates the SCP content
license creative commons share-alike 3.0
for a time the situation calmed as we
slowly pursued the dissolution of
dachshunds illegitimate trademark by
ross patent but it is nigh escalated
dachshund has recently resumed his
efforts to threaten and extort
competitors and has now begun to
threaten SCP itself he utilized the
element trademark to shut down the
official social media page of the
Russian branch of the SCP foundation
wiki as well as a separate fan page we
attempted to negotiate with VK the
social media company in question but as
long as the trademark registration
stands they will abide by it
night dachshund has followed this by
making a ridiculous demand to be
administrator of the Russian wiki and
that said wiki be twisted into an
advertisement for his merchandise rather
than the writing community that it is
these actions threaten not only the
Russian community but every SCP branch
writer and fan around the world
we stand with SCP Russia reject these
threats and are organizing a lawsuit
against dachshund to annul his false
trademark and prevent his continued
copyright infringement as an
organization of volunteers this is a
measure we do not often pursue due to
the costs involved last May when news of
dachshunds actions first became public
we received many offers from generous
SCP funds to donate to a legal fund at
the time we did not accept any offers as
we believed the situation could be
resolved via bureaucracy but what these
new developments this is no longer
possible as
such we humbly asked that anyone who
loves FCP on how some money to spare
doing it to our legal fund in order to
help protect our global community we are
still finalizing the details of the
fundraising and we'll have a second
round of the night Spence later in the
week once the donation page is ready the
SCP community maintains a united front
against Ducks ins threats please spread
the word about this situation on social
media using the hashtags stand with SCP
argue with your help SCP will continue
to thrive so it is November 12th right
now so at this date we do not have any
donation links we just don't have them
for a number of reasons but the second
that these donation links go live I'll
be posting them everywhere icon my
facebook my Twitter my youtube channel
my desk ORD every single Avenue I have
to promote this the links will be there
if you follow me at all you will see
them this needs to be stopped
I'm not gonna go through what I already
went through with my last video but this
is pretty much an emergency so I'm gonna
cut this off now if you have any
questions leave them in the comments and
I'll try and answer them I'm not an
official spokesperson for the SCP wiki
but I'll try and get them answered
thanks for listening if indeed you still
are and you're all dismissed goodbye